it seems to start out okay particles are
bouncing off of the jello and then uh-oh
look many of them seem to get stuck so
can we fix this somehow well this is
where this new paper comes into play
look here it starts out somewhat
similarly most of the particles get
pushed away from the jello and then look
some of them indeed keep bouncing for a
long long time and none of them are to
the jello glorious we can see the same
phenomenon here with three Jello blocks
of different stiffness values with this
we can also simulate more than 10,000
bouncy hair strands and to the Delight
of a computer Graphics researcher we can
even throw snow into it and expect it to
behave correctly